our Africa correspondent John sparks
traveled to the city of quackery to meet
him the man with the multicolored scarf
Emerson minagawa promises a miraculous
transformation of Zimbabwe and he's
looking and moving like a confident man
[Applause]
president Managua to pose the country's
longtime dictator Robert Mugabe last
November and he's seeking support for
the ruling Zanu PF party
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and in an exclusive interview with Sky
News the man once feared as Mugabe's
enforcer says it's time to break with
the past open for a new engagement
things have shaved no more violence we
want this we must preach unity we have
told the entire international community
that our elections are going to be free
fair transparent and credible but man
and gag was credibility is questioned
his former boss Robert Mugabe
intimidated his opponents and ret the
country's economy you've promised the
voters of Zimbabwe a new dawn new
freedoms new prosperity but you are
closely associated with the the old
regime why should voters trust you now
those who want to live in the past
we cannot present them to go into the
future but we are saying we are going to
diffusion who don't live in the past but
any democracy
you don't persuade the people to go with
you but you say let us move forward we
can only live for the future we can only
prepare for the future not for the bus
man and Jaguar has plenty of investors
on side the president spent the week
opening factories mines and this
chromium processing plant but his
critics say he's also got state TV and
the Electoral Commission working for him
this is the perception foreigners like
yourself we have if we have time look at
the Constitution find out how the
Commission is constituted and codes have
been put on standby in case anybody is
any query to date this nothing Amazon
Managua is in a tight race for the
presidency but he is convinced a victory
despite the baggage he carries
my self-esteem you see you from the
people Monday is the deciding factor
you see wonders wins npf again who run
to victory fantastic thank you very much
John sparks sky knees in quake way
Zimbabwe